hello and welcome everyone with morning
good afternoon and good evening my name
is Abbot I'm the host for today's
session 3 or we are on a webinar and
it's been arranged by simply learn one
of the most credible training provider
for digital age okay
it also offers our Rio to offer big data
analytics our digital marketing cloud
computing cybersecurity project
management IT service and architecture
mobile software development courses so
we are here to help you and in terms of
the facts about simply learn it's one of
the leading professional learning
globally claimed more than 50 thousand
learners more than 2000 enterprises are
with course completion percentage of
more than two a 72% and we have some
great trainers or accredited trainers of
400 plus courses offered so we had
simply learned offer provides you the
best learning experience
globally claim and with that note today
we are here on how to prepare your
nanotech team for your digital
transformation and it's by Ronald when
loon
he's our speaker Renault helps our data
driven companies generating business
value with Best of Breed solution and a
hands-on approach he has been recognized
as one of the top 10 global influencer
by date economy for pet productive
analytics and my cloud for data science
big data business intelligence data
mining and is great our guest author on
leading big data sites he's also a
speaker chairman and panel member of
national international webinars events
or runs
a successful series on big data and
digital transformation he has been
active in data management domain for
more than 18 years he has founded
multiple companies now a director at
avoid advertisement leader in Big Data
and data process management solution
he has brought interest in Big Data data
science predictive analytics business
intelligence customer experience data
mining and I mean if you ask me he we
have one of the great personality in
terms of modern world on big data and
data science if you would like to
connect with him feel free to connect
with him on Twitter or LinkedIn stay
updated on success stories so that's
about Ron I let me go ahead and unmute
Ron and welcome him here on can you hear
us yes a bit thanks a lot I appreciate
you having me here today and thank you
for the kind introduction a bit I want
to thank all of our listeners for
joining me today on this webinar event
as well today there's more data and more
changing behavior than ever before and
what we see is the progression of data
don't really show stocks
any sign of stopping and this has led to
the need for businesses to revolutionize
the way they manage the data and
analytics and with more channels more
devices and more data to manage the
customer journey holds an incredible
amount of impact and significant
significance for your business and
modern customers wants individualized
and highly relevant experience that
catered to their particular needs the
particular interest and their
preferences so it becomes of the utmost
importance for companies to make the
mission to cater for the individual
customer and the sheer amount of data
that businesses must harness in order to
provide a positive experience to the
customer its
really overwhelming in the last two
years over 90% of the world's data has
been created 90 percent it's incredible
everything generates data from social
media mobile devices website
interactions retail store purchases
everything every action that occurs on a
mobile device on a tablet cell or phone
car game devices healthcare equipment
etc everything produces data and
provides very valuable information about
individuals interacting with those
devices and if utilized properly this
customer information can be analyzed and
applied towards creating an even greater
more individualized customer experience
so what we see if we look into the near
future by 2020 80 percent of the buying
process will occur without any human
interaction let your hair drip right 80
percent of the buying process will occur
without any human interaction so
organizations must increase their
effectiveness in influencing the
customer journey towards a positive one
evolution of data and evolution from
customer control has altered the way
organizations manage their customer
experience and if you look like
companies like Apple Amazon and Google
they are data-driven organizations who
set the bar for personalized positive
customer experiences every other company
should tend to emulate this standard for
their customer experience that are
exceptional in all ways across all
brands touch points and it's about
elevating the experience for the
individual customer and making their
personal customer journey the focal
point of your business objectives I
spoke with the chief commercial officer
from a leading data-driven airline
recently about how their preference
utilized Wi-Fi while flying and the
amazing capability to be flying all over
the world at 5:00 from the 55 miles an
hour 35,000 feet in the air and yet
passengers get angry and frustrated when
the YouTube movie is disrupted by spotty
Wi-Fi but this is the norm now because
people have to come to expect a seamless
uninterrupted customer experience users
become accustomed to a new experience in
just 10 minutes
and after that time period they're used
to it and absolutely expected to work
there's a sense of entitlement that it's
connected to an individual interaction
with a business and with the products
and services and businesses need to work
harder to provide a fantastic customer
experience become a customer centric and
ensuring that the individual customer is
prime concern and it should be at the
forefront of any organizations list of
priorities so companies have to
determine how to create an extraordinary
customer experience when the customer is
in control
but
live behind all this change indeed data
analytics data and analytics drives the
customer experience data analytics is
changing the customer experience and
it's providing new and housed way of
businesses to interact with the
customers and improve their overall
journey and data analytics are capable
of going far beyond the typical insights
and reports that you may be used to and
can have marvelous compelling
applications in relation to customer
experience in ways that maybe almost
feel futuristic but I think though
they're currently just on reality
already
if you
Facebook Facebook uses facial
recognition software to automatically
deck images from photos that are
uploaded onto social media sites and
here data analytics is utilized to
identify Facebook users and suggest the
names of friends or families that are
identified from the photos this is also
data analytics paypal uses data
analytics through machine learning
algorithms to detect in a mere
split-second trustworthy customers from
those who pose a potential threat and
essentially it's a decision-making tool
that separates the good from the bad and
PayPal is able to combat fraud with this
technique and applying it towards other
areas of risk management as well yeah
who collects a massive amount of data
you do everybody knows and they analyze
it to detect where cyber attacks is
originating from and its response to
this automatically it's a form of system
security that protects the entire
organization and identified where and
how hackers are targeting their system
also this is data and analytics and
snapchat uses data and analytics as a
marketing tool to improve their
engagement with the targeted audience
and they were meant to predict who will
swipe an advertisement so this also
helps snapchat to draw in advertisers
and marketers with an optimized
automatic bidding system through this
tool they have seen a 40% increase in
efficiency in their cost per swipe
Microsoft Microsoft Kinect you probably
know it from from the gaming put gaming
into the hands of its users and this is
I think you can see it even literally by
enabling a gamer to use their hands and
the body as their controller so
basically they are the joystick and data
analytics provides information that's
used to define the body position and
connected to the gaming experience and
really in a revolutionary way and gamers
are able to interact with their video
games in a manner that feels more
immersive than traditional handheld
gaming
Tropes and this is well it's data and
analytics through data analytic the
healthcare industry is able to identify
stages of cancer in patients through
genome mapping and use the Intel to
guide therapy treatments machine
learning techniques patterns and
relationships with data are this profit
and applied towards predicting future
outcomes of this specific cancer and
this improves patient care and treatment
techniques and ensure that doctors and
other health care personnel are better
able to provide the right therapy
solution self-driven cars utilize data
analytics in very exciting ways to
innovating how machine learn can respond
to experience in the same manner
basically as human drivers they're
mimicking the actions and learning
experience from human drivers and
self-driving cars are able to recognize
objects and perceive its environments
and then define the actions for the car
which improves auto mode to say to
safety to an extensive degree and last
example is child fatality and the
customer care industry they use data
analysis to provide improved measures
for call support through natural
language recognition yes natural
language recognition is data analytics
which is an example of cognitive
analytics the newest most advanced trend
in analytics worlds it allows a better
experience for your customers and builds
loyalty by simulating an intelligent
human conversation with those who call
for existence in any number of areas
with all these compelling and innovative
uses of data and knit across the
industries organizations should not be
limited by the information at their
disposal Satan and NYX can be applied to
what improved customer experience in
ways restricted only by the imagination
so innovation can and basically shoot
starts today at your organization as
well
if you look to the number of touch
points the number of customer touch
points will only grow to continue about
50% and today about 50% of the customer
journey goes over multiple channels so
one channel for example call center to
the rep this is multiple channel and 50%
of the journeys are applicable to this
and companies need to be ready to be
able to respond to this growth via all
kinds of modern big data and analytics
tools and technologies and this is
particularly important because the
amount of customer touch points will
increase substantially this coming years
there's even more touch points and
ecosystems that are growing where you
need to measure the whole customer
journey and this change is only constant
and all of these constantly changing
customer behaviors progression of data
in the world around us and the boom of
ammount of data generated in the last
few years alone for just one important
questions how the businesses organize to
prepare for this change
prior to detailing in real depth I want
to briefly outline the topics to be
discussed today and offer an overview of
how businesses can begin organizing and
preparing for this change organizations
need to focus on the following first
multidisciplinary teams second modern
technology third trusted analytic
solutions and fourth maybe the most
important is the people capabilities and
education your organization
and processes includes includes creating
an a gel multidisciplinary team that
stresses the role of each team member
and whether it's a data scientist an
engineer a designer and it should be
able to splitting data collection and
application and I will go in much more
depth later on in the in the webinar and
this will spark unity across all these
departments instead of the silos and
encouraging collaboration and sharing
data and the insights from the data the
technology should target first at
analytics for dependability and
consistency of this data inside as well
for credibility and integrity of your
data this is supported by modern open
source technologies and you can think
about technologies like Hadoop but the
positives like spark business have to be
able to have a complete confidence in
the data output this should be trust and
a modern technology is the medium by
which they attain data and analytics
trust Trust is really really crucial in
in becoming a data-driven company and
managing your digital transformation
your people and capabilities is fighting
towards organizing for your digital
information because data and analytics
is a discipline that's relevant because
all all organizations and whether you
talk about finance when you talk about
marketing sales operation and any other
department they are directly influenced
and affected by data and analytics and
you must have the right people and the
right capabilities in place to
efficiently and effectively manage it
education is interconnected to this as
its getting trained and obtaining
knowledge in this field regardless of
what your role you occupy within your
organization it can be an enormous
impact to your career and how you relate
to it and work with it and this data
those who handle it and all the people
around it that handles data even the
type II personnel as well and plus
giving her
technology evolves people have to be
able to keep the pace with the changes
if they want to stay relevant and
knowledgeable about the latest trends
latest tools and latest technologies
it's amazing how fast this development
goes organizations also need to move a
maturity level from let's say compliant
analytics which is a first phase to
cognitive analytics which I gave you the
example with natural language
recognition and this natural progression
that's better described as the old adage
you need to learn to crawl before you
can walk and this is how businesses at
falls to become truly data-driven not
simply data conscious business
strategies and endures become realized
when a company reaches its full
analytics potential and lastly companies
need to become use case driven to
develop more effective strategies and to
achieve their business goals and these
topics we will go in much more depth
with in this webinar and constantly
changing customer behaviors and the
progression of data encourages business
to ask three important questions and
this is also the topic for the webinar
today so how do you prepare your data
and analytics team for digit
transformation this year not next year
and how to derive value from your data
before that how to become data-driven of
course so what is the role of the
customer journey and how to structure
your organization as I stated earlier 50
percent of the customer journey from
multi-channel but they're also multi
event across time journeys so it becomes
imperative for organizations to support
cross channel events to promote positive
customer journey regarding the use of
silos versus multidisciplinary teams
it's imperative to understand the
difference between the two and I will go
in more depth in the next slides and
it's important to understand why they
impact businesses neck
start with setting up data management
from multiple sources that reinforce
reporting over all these touch points
companies need to make a positive
impression on the customers at the
moment of the customer interaction and
they experience your brand so if they're
in contact with your brand any touch
points and businesses and need to move
towards this step in the whole process
towards a purchase but even after the
purchase because
with IOT Internet of Things you can also
have insights in how people use your
products because humans form strong
emotional based opinions about companies
based upon these touch points so every
interaction every touch point they have
with your company it's important so it's
crucial that it's a positive experience
or you risk losing your customers to
your competitors ensuring that the touch
points are positive throughout every
channel it's key which is why
organisations must have an HR
multidisciplinary team and silos only
represent a single point of a customer
journey they do not support customer
journeys or experiences data is not
shared across channels and priorities
don't align with other departments
within your organization it's difficult
to build or support the positive
customer experience from this from the
structure when there's no internal
unification across departments and
across this channel this insular
approach to data analytics makes it very
difficult to obtain a complete picture
of your business data and a complete
picture of the customer journey
so therefore multidisciplinary teams
support cross-functional events to
create a positive customer journey from
mobile shopping to email campaigns to
mobile marketing to sales billing life
support the customer journey occurs
throughout a variety of channels that
all must lead to a positive experience
multidisciplinary teams encourage
collaboration across the teams and and
management to promote a more unified
focus and common goals not departmental
goals emphasizing teamwork and helping
to ensure that everyone is striving
towards the same outcome to create a
better customer experience a silo based
our organizations are not viable now
neither in the future departmental silos
are inefficient inaccessible show-up
sighted and self-centered the hinder
productivity and limit day
accessibility across teams the reduce
efficiency and they prevent the adaption
and growth of data-driven culture so how
do you support a client in its customer
journey if you work with silos you can
begin by focusing on a single important
customer journey and improve parts of it
by supporting the journey with just a
few data sources very easy to start very
effective
however businesses need to focus on a
consistent path to purchase and path the
relationship stay clear of the silo
mentality and move away from traditional
customer service approach preparing your
team for these transform transformation
means encouraging sharing information
across departments working together
towards shared goals and building an
information ecosystem supported by data
and analytics and Netflix I think is a
perfect example of a company who's
utilizing a multi-channel approach to
redefine the customer experience in the
media industry and improve
personalization of their content the
customer has so many options today and
access to wide range of stream of
content at Netflix but Netflix is able
to deliver a very very personalized
content to the customers based upon the
information provided by data and
analytics they're able to determine if a
movie is watched to completion if a user
rewind to certain points in the movie
where they navigate to after finishing
the television show how long they're in
the Netflix app and what they are
searching for while they're engaging
with the menu a Netflix is exit
accessing customer sentiment in real
time because there's a sophisticated
application of modern data analytic
techniques and ensuring that they can
suggest content to the users that
appeals to them on an emotional basis
which is fantastic an Amazon is another
sector company who takes an innovative
multi-channel approach to drive and
customer experience to a whole other
level of customization
innovation they've introduced a small
smart speaker
called echo which is the voice
controlled and it offers an interactive
experience for the customers the echo
learns about the person's needs and
about his preferences as responds by
delivering a seamless experience as well
as personalized purchasing suggestions
on the Amazon as it gets to know the
customer how to use it the MOR a
customer interacts with echo the more
responsive the device can be to a
person's needs so now to expand upon
multidisciplinary teams
multidisciplinary teams comprised of
data analysts data scientists designers
and project managers all of which help
businesses to respond fast to market
change and enable versatile knowledge of
tools and technologies that you can
apply it to make improve decisions for
example a customer who submits a
mortgage application requires support
from an entire team he's not dealing
with a single person over the course of
his entire application the customer
submits its mortgage application and
speaks to marketing representative about
pre-qualification requirements then the
application goes through a various
processing in mint multiple departments
until it's finally approved and moved
into closing and this cures over
multiple departments and is handled at
different teams who have to share data
about the individual customer in order
to process this application swiftly and
bring it to an accurate conclusion this
example demonstrates the effectiveness
and importance of multidisciplinary
teams working together towards a
positive outcome of the for the customer
a multidisciplinary teams are the best
way to promote integration and
collaboration of data insights ensuring
that a positive customer experience is
the responsibility of the entire
interpreting departmental team so not
only from one depart
a gel multidisciplinary teams are also
important for supporting data management
and data governments
it's about capability the resources and
processes there needs to be roles for
data engineers or data scientists data
analyst and a project manager within the
HR customer centric team so what roles
need to be filled for a data science
team you need to have a data scientist
who can work on large data sets and we
understand the theory behind the science
it should be able and capable of
developing predictive models and data
engineers and data software developers
are important too they need to
understand the architecture the
infrastructure and the distributed
program the exact team configuration is
of course dependent upon your situation
and whether you're in as well in the
application where we go in-depth later
on in the application part or you're in
the part of data management big data
management and forms analytics some of
the roles to fill in a data scientist
include data solution architect take a
platform administrator full set
developers and designers and if you have
a team that has a lot of skill that is
low in real-world experience you may
also want to have a project manager on
the team and they can help keep up the
team to the right track and encourage
productivity and with the support and
capability of a multidisciplinary team
to foster a data-driven culture in your
organization and your ability to execute
a positive customer experience is not
only possible but if you organize like
this
it's even expected next to the organ
structure technology is key in your
digital transformation we go
infrastructures and technologies
business needs the power and the
capability fast accurate data
infrastructure provided by modern
technology and analytic solutions a
traditional tool based approach for
departments pieces of data landscape or
by debt collection and preparation is
part of the processing and storage so
it's the whole chain from data
management that's managed by this that's
a departmental tools organization that
to continue with the silo driven
approach will struggle with empowering
the business users are being able to
share data visualization across the
departments across your whole business
and they have no data possibility so
they cannot share your data to all the
different sources and they rely on
consolidated enterprise text data is
simply isolated and businesses are
forced to be limited by the means to
utilize and apply data to its full
potential
multiple tools can contain the complete
process of data creation collection
processing storage and utilization and
work together to improve the operation
analyzing the data
high performance data analytics tools
provide businesses with proactive means
to attain insights from the information
and make it easier for organizations to
manage large volumes of data
a fully integrated point solution and
neighbor companies controlled through
what Gnostic and reduce technologies
that are 100% GDP are compliant and this
is I think mainly for the European
audience today there's a new law in 2018
where you need to be compliant it's a
new law on privacy and you are allowed
to ask for approval for everything how
you use today how to use the data and
probably it's less relevant for the US
and for the Indian ordinance today
organizations utilize a modern approach
to data and analytics have full control
over the data and they are able to
accommodate diverse data sets and can
combine large amounts of data from
various departments and systems and
additionally data is better governed to
manage without requiring specialized
support from IT
so the main point over here is the data
collection and the creation should be
centralized currently no company is
doing this but it's important to become
data-driven and to create the
data-driven culture and then if you have
to select technology businesses may be
wondering which data analytics tool to
use when there's a peer thorough of
tools which you choose from you see an
overview over here which is only a
selection closed-source versus open
source options and the depending of
course on the specific needs that you
have on your organization and as well on
the technical resources you have and the
people you have in the organization
however open source is starting to
become more popular trend and it becomes
more and more mature and more more
business want to have end-to-end
solution and entrance access to data and
emphasize trust and collaboration and
open source tools and sticks become
better and better for this as well so
trusting
data that you use is vital which is why
businesses need to emphasize the
importance of trusted analytics
credibility of an analytic output
supported by process that's able to
build trust on the insights promotes a
modern data and analytics environment
you have to build your stack with the
right people processes and collaboration
for the best data management and it's
important to use a data and analytics
spec from tools that work well together
and cover four important disciplines
have to cover the security the software
framework the data science toolkit and a
collaboration these four disciplines
model covers analytics tools but to not
cover the application parts so the
application where users in the
department's normally use it for example
organizations should integrate an
open-source data management stick that's
a combination of various tools that
provide a complete solution so stick and
it's scalable modular and again promotes
collaboration and thriving a data-driven
culture an example for this is Cave it's
kept in KPMG framework and it's example
of a big data platform that's well
designed and adaptive to the situation
for all different kinds of sizes it
embraces annalistic approach to data
science inclusive security a software
framework the data science toolkit and
collaborative tools and Dave generates a
flexible data environment that evolves
with an organization and can grow with
it open source techno
Jesus we've discussed ideal to create an
intelligence sharing and corporation
corporate organization that promotes
transparency of data and an open
exchange of your information the ease of
scalability is also an appealing factor
for businesses who predict expansion or
migration at some point in future open
source technology benefit everyone not
just the programmers which have
specialized knowledge in this this
businesses users can can have power over
their own data in real time and leverage
business solutions accordingly currently
tools a solutions like Hadoop and spark
are two of the most popular Big Data
frameworks spark is becoming
increasingly desirable and is supported
by large companies like IBM as well
which gives an enormous boost and its
simplicity and high quality performance
capability and the flexibility are
extremely valuable assets for a variety
of business models however it's its
speed is a highly coveted quality among
many organization and it's real time
processing which can be used in a
variety of big data applications a dupe
is also popular choice for companies
that have massive complex datasets that
require an effective solution in a
reasonable quick time frame for
processing large data set it's an
excellent option a dupe also has its own
distributed file system which is
fundamental to many modern Big Data
projects spark and aduke are compatible
and can be used together to generate big
data solutions and some businesses
install spark on top of Hadoop which
Park at forest analytics application can
utilize data stored within the Hadoop
distributed file system and other
popular tools analytics tools includes
even Excel but also sauce are fightin
and bi tools like the blow and there's
only one simple reason why they use this
type of tool
is to increase cost-effectiveness
usability customization and scalability
to your interior
we discussed organizational structure
and technology next we will be we will
discuss the most important assets you
have in your organization and that's
your people data and analytics are
critical to your business and they're
relevant to all other disciplines in
your organization whether it's finance
whether it's marketing whether sales
operation technology all interconnect
the departments that are supported by
data and analytics and this is empowered
by the expertise and skills of your
people and their individual and
collective roles within your
organization companies have to organize
analytics which is the support aspect of
your infrastructure per department and
customer journey and centrally to create
a visualization for this concept picture
it as a representative of the heart of
your organization supporting all other
functions data analytics data governance
data management visualization and data
science are enabling and supporting
durational excellence and the positive
customer journey
continuing with the visualization of a
business as a functional organic life
form imagine your company company's data
analytics personnel as the brains of
your organization they support knowledge
and skills and fulfill specialized roles
that enable the successful operation and
fulfillment of your company's strategies
and goals and the outcomes deciding
whether it's best to outsource or rely
on in-house personnel or utilize a
combination of the two options in order
to speed up the process is a very
important consideration businesses need
to have bailed themselves of whatever
resources are going to be best silted a
fast-paced modern data and analytics
environment and there's a need for one
million data scientist by 2018
and we're witnessing a widening data
scientists kept that's a barrier to
business growth even companies have to
utilize and deliver insights to keep
achieving in innovation and to achieving
their business value but how do we solve
this dilemma of a shortage of data
scientist education and training of your
team is absolutely crucial and
continuous education is just as
important as hiring and recruiting
externally it's an expensive alternative
to internal education because the
efficiency would suggest that business
leaders took look to internal solutions
for education not only with outside data
science is a highly sought-after and
lucrative career option as well with
available positions across a diverse
range of industries and education will
help motivate the professional to get
the foot in the door those people who
are already data scientist can still
benefit from education to further hone
and refine their skills and stay
relevant within a rapidly evolving
technology based industry education is
also important so that everyone in your
organization speaks the same language
and can communicate effectively and
efficiently with one another and
technology changes extremely fast and
people need to stay up-to-date to derive
the most value out of the data knowledge
of data give business users the power to
predict the future outcomes and gain
insight as to risk and to business
opportunities companies need and want
professionals who are certified in data
science in data analytics and other
relevant specializations and who possess
knowledge of data trends and modern
tools and technologies in getting
certified in a relevant field dan please
basically your career growth
so how do businesses manage these
challenges the organization's maturity
phase indicates the effectiveness of
your ability to accurately utilize data
to drive business decisions and promotes
an excellent customer experience a
mature organization can offer valuable
data and analytic services that are
aligned to and progress with business
priorities and with business strategies
they're also able to provide government
access to data wherever they exist
within an organization and can give
meaning and context to it they're more
innovative in their data application and
can predict future outcomes
organizations have to be use case and
customer journey driven to improve the
customer experience we've discussed it
before and remember the crawl before you
walk analogy that I mentioned earlier
starting with data inside a business has
to move from data awareness by step to
predictive analytics start at the
beginning the maturity phases start with
descriptive analytics whereby data is
used to comprehend the past and the
present this is the initial stage of an
organization development a stage in
which a business is looking back at
historical data and producing standard
reports data is utilized to answer
questions about what happened in the
past but as historical data can only
reveal a limited amount of information
this phase is detrimental to generating
business value
and determining where the future
customer will come from and discovering
insight about future issues that will
affect your organization from there it
progresses to predictive analytics the
developing stage of business analytics
maturity the maturity phase and this
maturity phase companies are able to
extra mine data and apply it towards
predicting the future trends and
predicting the activities that your
customer will apply it enables
organizations to answer questions such
as what could happen if I change this
specific friable
techniques utilized in this stage
include predictive modeling forecasting
and statistical analysis predictive
analytics enables risk and opportunity
assessments to its best advantage for
example airlines use predictive
analytics to forecast mechanical
failures so that they can minimize
flight cancellations and delays data is
applied in real-time to predict the type
of mechanical issue that will cause a
delay or cancellation within the next 24
hours
enabling airlines to take preventative
measures this results in an improved
customer experience because people
aren't aggravated and forced to change
their travel plans last-minute
analytics is where they are capable of
predicting future outcomes and
prescribing the ideal course of action
as they learn from the data insights and
according to sources such as Gartner 10%
of organizations use some form of
prescriptive analytics only 10% but this
will grow to 35% at 2020 and then
cognitive analytics is the final stage
driving innovation and technology
transformation into the future a
cognitive system offers real-time
solutions and on the mountainsides and
learning from interactions and existing
information
so lots of things are going on but
you're on a business and
to start tomorrow tomorrow in your own
business how to start simply how to
start to crawl how do you start to digit
transformation tomorrow first focus on
education and certification you won't be
able to advance in your chosen career or
communicate with members of your team
where there's a skill barrier standing
in the way you need to possess the
knowledge and the language to stay
abreast of current technologies tools
and industry trends and give the pace of
growth and innovation for data analytics
it's wise to stay educated so you can
continue to be relevant in this in this
field also start by purchasing prior to
prioritizing your customer journey you
can begin by improving one important
journey for your business and just
connect one two three data sources
starting small and building upwards
working towards creating favorable
customer experience should be the main
goal to keep aiming for but starting
small and realistically with one
customer journey that's a good place to
begin start simple but start tomorrow
visual transformation cannot occur
without concentrating on applying
internal efforts towards using data and
obtain better more trustworthy insights
so start by splitting your data
collection I showed in the example from
the infrastructure and your application
and enable all departments and
disciplines within an organization to
work together more predictively and will
full control over your data trusted
insights will help you to generate value
from your data and leverage it to enrich
your opportunities and your business
potential you should start also
implementing your customer-centric
multidisciplinary team including the
data analyst that they decide this data
engineers and project managers you want
to build cooperation and sharing across
your organization and improve
capabilities resources and processes
that will help you develop better
business solutions with a milk
disciplinary team supporting patients
and providing diverse skills and
knowledge you can work towards creating
a high quality personalized customer
experience because that's in the end the
aim you're cheering for I start with
data insights to move a step by step is
a move to watch step by step going to
predictive but this can be a long road
so you can eventually develop it into an
advanced maturity phase but take your
time building analytics trust along this
path is crucial enable your business
users to perform their own analytics
without the need of IT very important
self-service enable them and benefit
from improved decisions making based on
accuracy and deeper insight derived from
more complex information mature use of
analytics not only reshapes the customer
experience for better but it also
elder's your entire infrastructure to
make data-driven analytics more you
because throughout your company being
data-driven is what will inform your
decisions for customization your
business
when this webinar to a close I want to
reiterate the importance of receiving a
solid education and acquiring the
knowledge and skills that are necessary
to ensure your career growth and keeping
the gap the 60% gap of data scientists
in minds remember that education and
certification will best position you to
respond to this need those who are
looking to get certified and data
science and move into the professional
landscape can also of course look at the
course function to learn and get started
your journey to becoming a participant
in this rapidly accelerating industry
it's fascinating
she knows already in this field consider
getting continued training and
certification courses that will enable
you to involve with the technology and
tools your trade with so then don't let
yourself behind ensure that you can keep
up with transforming your digital worlds
created yourself I would like to extend
an invitation I have to all the
listeners and open up the webinar for
any type of question thank you so much
for that run and before we go ahead and
do a quick question and answer session I
would like to launch the poll and
request each one of you to just select
and take up the poll for a minute it
still takes less than 30 seconds to just
give your poll so do not skip that and
we are open for the questions now round
we we have a question coming in from
Rowan who Said's are any challenges
faced by the new world companies
introducing IOT example the industry or
worship for typical manufacturing or
industry on this so you if you could
provide some insights on this question
please
okay so IOT Internet of Things so
basically every device whether it's a
car but it's your mobile computer garage
door every device is basically their
sensor edits to these devices so every
device generates data and if you look to
the whole data chain you start
collecting data from the customer
journey and the customer journey starts
when there's a first contact with your
client and it can be via a banner can be
a line can be in a retail store that can
be from a call center there's a first
contact and this whole journey from
first contact going through a tablet or
a mobile going to a retail store
ordering something and start using the
product where the products starts let's
say sending data is this whole journey
and IOT is just an extension of the data
journey so
G gives companies the ability and the
possibility to improve even better the
customer experience because they can
understand better their their clients
but this also brings some additional
challenges so challenges if you start
collecting data from devices one
important challenge of security so how
to solve your security for your device
that the device is not hacked
another challenge is data governance who
owns the doubt data and how to get
consent approval how to use this data
the third item is let's say that the
volume and variety and the veracity so
there's tremendous amount of data that
is generated from all these sensors so
how to handle this how can old system
handle this and there you see the
requirements for real-time processing
and technologies like spark that should
be applied to manage this in your let's
say call architecture so there are
technical challenges on one hand and on
the other hand of course there's people
and processes so how to manage all that
your process internally to collect this
data to process it and to derive value
and insights from it this means that
you're not you cannot work as a
department as a product department for
example and you're responsible for the
product now you should work from a team
a multidisciplinary team which is
responsible for the whole customer
journey from first contact maybe to
product application and within this team
you can split it up in small teams and
you can improve important parts from
your products for example and there you
can split up your the smaller team but
there will be people involved from sales
from marketing and customer service from
your product development and also also
data analysts and data scientists so IOT
brings a whole range of opportunities
but also a whole range of challenges
that needs to be managed
thanks for that and run the next
question is what should be the ideal
data signs our theme for the market
place starting up using our consumer
insights rewards spending patterns so
you have any analysis on this yeah so
ideal team success rate on conversion
I'm sorry
so ideal team really depends on the
situation I think important if you start
defining a team it's defining from which
touch points you have in your customer
journey so and which departments are
involved in this customer journey so
it's the people for marketing for these
two people from sales involved customer
service so which touch point are you
improving so this is I think the the
foundation if you talk about teams if
you didn't start talking about what
let's say data analytics people should
be involved if you look from the
application side there should be an
analyst involved in the team if you as
mentioned already if the team is a
little bit less mature you should
involve a project manager if you look to
the part where you need to have a data
scientist so if you need to have your
data let's say collection you're you're
processing providing insights defining
models if you are this level from
predictive analytics you need to have a
data scientist for collecting the data
you need to have a data engineer
somebody who can collect the data take
care for the data quality and take care
basically that the data the data
governance is managed as well so there's
not a fixed team that generates the
ideal team but there's a number of
different of roles that should be
basically part of this team and you
really define this
you define this depending on the
customer journey and the purpose that
that you want to achieve if you're more
let's say in the data management part so
then you have to yes people have
understand the architecture understand
the infrastructure and understand to
distribute programming so then you need
much more data the technology side from
from the data if you're more on the
application side you need more the
people that are into analysis so the the
business analyst analyst and the data
analyst analyst okay things and there is
a question on certification as well and
this goes on our to organization with
that is embarking or being better at the
data and data driven marketing place or
client
what will your recommendation on on on
the startups and so if I understand the
question well what do I recommend
startups from certification perspective
of which are which are being data-driven
from from start for startups correct
yeah and I think if you look let's say
whether you are started or whether you a
mid-sized company or whether you a very
large corporate you see the way the
company starts organizing to be data
driven is from a customer's journey
perspective and it's from a
multidisciplinary team perspective so
what you see is anyhow you start with
working with small multidisciplinary
teams and if you were started of course
you don't have less legacy so which is
much easier compared to the large
corporation but in fact the cooler and
the cool way of working this agile way
of working is the same so also from
the perspective of education and
certification in certification is
crucial to stay up-to-date with the fast
changing technology it's crucial to
speak the same language and it's crucial
to let's say stay up to date with all
the knowledge that you need from
programming perspective analytics
perspective so it doesn't differ that
much whether you were startup or whether
you're large corporates because you need
to think from small teams and define the
education that you need from small teams
that you let's say have all required
capabilities within the team for the
face you're in and whether you're in the
descriptive phase and just look back you
need other capabilities then you are
working with predictive models or even
working on cognitive analytics so
there's also a huge difference from this
maturity perspective so
would say it's not the company size that
defines how to define your education
it's more the type of customer journey
and the maturity phase you're in that
defines what type of education and what
kind of certification you need at that
moment because I think it's good for the
the person who asked this question to go
more in depth what the situation is and
discuss a situation and see how we can
help them with a nice let's say path how
to develop the capabilities with within
their teams great and in terms of
technology the last one for you on on
this run and how would your cloud
benefit this data-driven journey and
what how can any any barriers can be
overcome so in case in case either you
have any any barriers on cloud or the
updation so how how can we overcome okay
I think the choice for clouds really
depends on your industry as well and so
if you look to the financial industry
governmental and they have a lot of
regulations so the choice for clouds or
on-premises or a hybrid solution it's
depending on rules and governance
security issues that you have so there's
not let's say a black-and-white answer
for this so depending on the industry
you see different type of choices either
clouds either on-premise or either a
hybrid solution and if you look to the
maturity and the possibilities and
clouds of course is easier and faster
often in your deployment but
core in the end is there should be
analytics trust and if you cannot govern
your data that that fits with your
process for you within your organization
it will not work so cloud is not the
roots it's the root depends really on
your business and depends on on your
requirements but I think from technology
perspective it doesn't matter too much
whether it's cloud hybrid or whether
it's on-premise solutions all solutions
exist and all solutions work well and
all solutions have its own challenges of
course and so it's more a matter of the
correct execution then of the one over
the other choice
all right things and and the last one
again on on certification what will be
the basic certification in which the one
should choose to take up so yeah as well
and back to the to the transfer I
provided it already before certification
really depends in the face where you are
so whether are you starting with data
you're more in the descriptive maturity
phase are you already looking ahead with
data and start predicting a building
predictive models are you in the area of
cognitive analytics this really depends
on what type of certification you need
and where you are and it's really let's
a mix of blended different type of roles
and different types of certifications
you need to have the ideal team so for
every question if you're not looking to
a person but more to a team within your
organization
I rather start with the question okay
what's your maturity what is your type
of customer journey in which let's say
which industry you're in and based upon
this we can define and the best route
for a1 and certification and education
and developing your capabilities from
your team along with your process that
you going through the maturity phases
instead of saying okay this is the best
certifications for you it really depends
on the situation so so in it there's no
concrete answer but if it was this this
easy yeah then I think data analytics
was a let's say a much more mature
Department already in the last 50 years
but it's it's not very easy it's it's a
tough job but it's something that is
material now and can be evolved very
quickly
a great r-run thank you and that was the
last question from my end and again
thank you so much for all your expertise
on the knowledge post guys again you've
you've done at the right choice tending
to simply learn website or the webinar
the most credible training provider for
the digital age so we look forward to
interact with you on any any aspect of
upcoming learnings in once again I would
like to thank Ron all the attendees
Priyanka on this session do fill out the
feedback form at the end of the session
not skip that it's important that we get
to know your insights on this again
thank you so much Ron welcome we'll come
to a closure now and see you next time
on the next session Thanks
you